[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta slomker guten Abend
Frau Leben Freiheit als die Vorsitzende
des Nobelpreiskomitees heute Vormittag
zunächst nur die diese drei Worte sprach
war sofort klar wohin der diesjährige
Friedensnobelpreis gehen würde in den
Iran stellvertreten für die iranische
Frauen und
Menschenrechtsbewegung bekommt ihn
narges mohamedi die 51-Jährige
Aktivistin steht für alles was diese
Bewegung ausmacht für den Mut für die
Unbeugsamkeit für die Verzweiflung für
die Qualen die ihnen vom iranischen
Regime angetan werden nagess mohamedi
sitzt im Gefängnis sie hat ihre Kinder
seit mehr als 8 Jahren nicht mehr
gesehen sie hat ein Buch über die
Folterungen geschrieben die dort
alläglich sind sie ist schwer krank sie
will dennoch weiterkämpfen kameran
safiarian
berichtet es sind diese mutigen
Auftritte die sie zur Ikone der Frauen
und Menschenrechtsbewegung in Iran
gemacht haben nesse Mohammadi 51 Jahre
Menschenrechtsaktivistin immer wieder
legt sie den Finger in die Wunde des
g dann hat sein volterer so lange auf
ihn eingeschlagen bis er tot
war warum nur ist das Haar der Frauen
das aus dem Kopftuch herausschaut das
einzige was euch noch
interessiert seit über drei Jahrzehnten
engagiert sich Mohammadi für
Frauenrechte und gegen die Todesstrafe
in Iran während der Proteste 2022 deckt
sie auf Frau änissen gefoltert und
missbraucht werden immer wieder wird sie
verhaftet auch jetzt sitzt sie im
Gefängnis und wird
gefoltert ich erkläre hiermit dass ich
keine Angst habe vor Peitschenhieben und
einer weiteren Gefängnisstrafe die
iranische Regierung soll wissen dass es
ihr nicht gelingen wird mich mit
Unterdrückung Gefängnis peitschenheben
und Folter zum Schweigen zu
bringen und somft sie auch a dem Wien
Gefängnis weiter macht Frauen Mut für
ihre Rechte zu kämpfen in
haftunterbrechungen dreht sie white
torture ein Dokument über die Folter und
unmenschliche Einzelhaft im berüchtigten
er wiin
Gefängnis dafür zahlt sie einen hohen
Preis insgesamt 31 Jahre Haft und 154
Peitschenhiebe diesen Kampf würdigt das
Nobelkomitee heute mit dem
Friedensnobelpreis und dem Slogan der
Freiheitsbewegung S
s women life
freedom große Freude heute bei
mohammadis Ehemann der mit den beiden
Kindern in Paris lebt die Kinder haben
ihre Mutter seit Jahren nicht mehr
[Musik]
gesehen heute ist der Widerstand des
iranischen Volkes belohnt worden der
Widerstand im Innern des Iran der
Widerstand im Gefängnis der Widerstand
auch einer iranischen Frau die neben
vielen anderen Frauen kämpft ihre Namen
sollten wir nicht
vergessen ein Preis der auch ein Signal
an die Protestbewegung ist ein Jahr nach
dem gewaltsamen Tod von Gina m Amini
liegt wieder ein junges Mädchen im Koma
laut Aktivisten misshandelt von der
Sittenpolizei der Friedensnobelpreis
heute macht vielen in Iran
Hoffnung ich hoffe dass dieser Preis den
Weg für uns Frauen öffnen wird weiter
voranzugehen in einer Gesellschaft in
der Frauen keine Rechte haben kann
dieser Preis ein Signal sein dass es
noch irgendjemand gibt auf dieser Welt
der auf uns schaut das Regime in teeran
hat den Friedensnobelpreis naras
Mohammadi verurteilt für die Menschen im
Land ist es ein historischer
Tag darüber wollen wir mit einer der
Mitstreiterinnen von narges mohammedi
sprechen mit
parastuis sie ist Frauen
Menschenrechtsaktivistin Künstlerin und
Professor an der Kunsthochschule in
Mainz guten Abend Frau
FA guten Abend wie schätzen Sie das ein
was bedeutet dieser Nobelpreis für diese
Bewegung in
Iran das bedeutet große Anerkennung als
die
Komitee diese ankundigung mit der Slogan
der Iraner Frau Leben Freiheit sansind
geod die angefangen hat das war wirklich
so wie eine laute schöne solidarische
Rufe nach Iran und das kommt auch dazu
dass es in einem Moment
der große unterdruckung diese
solidarische Ruf natürlich eine große
Freude eine Welle der Freude auch mit
sich zieht sie kennen Nagas Mohammed ja
persönlich sehr gut sie ist im Gefängnis
sie hat aber in irgendeiner Form ja
offenbar davon erfahren malen sie sich
aus was das für ein Moment für sie
gewesen sein muss in diesem grauenhaften
Situation dann so eine Nachricht zu
bekommen
n es ist ein sehr kollegiale Mensch sie
hat bestimmt mit iher Mitgefangenen
getanzt sie sinkt sehr gerne sie hat
gesunken und sie hat sich bestärkt
gefühlt um diese
Kampfe so standhaft wie sie ist
weiterzuführen und natürlich hat sie
sich auch gewunscht dass sie diese
Moment mit ihre Familie mit ihre beide
Kinder die weit weg von ihr im Exil
leben teilen könnte
mm sie hatten selbst im berühmte
dissidenteneltern die beide Ende der
90er Jahre bestialisch ermordet wurden
und seitdem fahren sie jedes Jahr zurück
in Iran am Todestag ihrer Eltern um um
daran zu gedenken und natürlich damit
auch Protest zum Ausdruck zu bringen nun
waren Sie das letzte Mal letztes Jahr im
Iran was ist ihr Eindruck wo steht diese
Protestbewegung im Moment man hat so ein
bisschen den Eindruck sie ist eigentlich
doch brutal niedergeschlagen
worden die Brutalität des Regimes ist
wirklich
unerträglich aber die Bewegung geht
weiter sogar heute gab es Demonstration
in Provinz baluces
weiterhin gehen viele junge Frauen
besondes unverschleiert auf die Straße
die sind die ruckrat diese Bewegung und
auch wenn das Regime mit Brutalität die
Demonstrationen verhindert kann diese
große Wandel in der Gesellschaft nicht
zurückdrehen die Menschen werden siegen
über dieses System sie haben nach ihrem
letzten Besuch letztes Jahr als nach
ihrer rückhör im November Dezember dann
in einem Interview gesagt dass sie einem
alten Weggefährten ihre Eltern begegnet
sind inzwischen über 90 Jahre ein Mann
der auch immer für Demokratie gekämpft
hat und er hätte zu ihnen gesagt weiß du
ähm ihr Frauen ihr werdet für uns
Siegen dass äh diese Satz war für mich
so kostbar und ich äh höre das immer
wieder in meinen Gedanken und es ist
eine Bestärkung und das er behält recht
wir sehen das dass äh diese Bewegung WD
hauptsächlich auf die Rucken der Frauen
getragen und umso wichtiger ist es dass
diese Frauen gewürdigt werden und
solidarisch äh begleitet werden fr ich
danke ihn sehr für dieses
Gespräch danke
Ihnen das Interview haben wir vor einer
Stunde geführt nachher im heute journal
Update gibt es noch ein Interview mit
der
Frauenrechtsaktivistin Mass
alineat das zweite große Ereignis heute
ist der EU-Gipfel in Granada wo einiges
schieflief dazu kommen wir gleich aber
erstmal machst du weiter Heinz der
Bundespräsident des in den USA relativ
spontan ja eigentlich war für heute ein
Termin Frank waltersteinm in Portugal
vorgesehen aber dann kam die Information
dass er auf Einladung von US-Präsident
Joe Biden nach Washington reist und für
den Nachmittag Ortszeit war dann Stein
als Besuch im Weißen Haus vorgesehen für
das erste Treffen der beiden als
Staatsoberhäupter laut
Bundespräsidialamt hat beiden den Tag
der deutsch-amerikanischen Freundschaft
am 6 oktober für den Besuch
vorgeschlagen das weiße hausalte mit es
gehe auch um die enge Abstimmung als
natobündnispartner in einer Reihe
wichtiger Fragen einschließlich der
Verteidigung demokratischer Werte und
der gemeinsamen Verpflichtung zur
Unterstützung der
Ukraine nach dem Angriff auf das Dorf
rosa in der Ostukraine will die UNO ein
Ermittlerteam dorthins schicken etwa 50
Menschen waren gestern dem Ort getötet
worden zur Zeit deute alles auf einen
russischen Raketenangriff hin sagte ein
unosprecher heute gab es weitere
Luftangriffe in harkiv haben Raketen ein
Wohngebiet getroffen ein 10 Jahre altes
Kind und seine Großmutter wurden tot in
den Trümmern gefunden nach ukrainischen
Angaben wurden 30 Menschen
verletzt
der frühere US-Präsident Trump hat sich
in der Diskussion um den künftigen
Vorsitzenden des Repräsentantenhauses zu
Wort gemeldet er unterstützt als
republikanischen Kandidaten für die
Nachfolge des abgewählten Kevin mccary
den Abgeordneten Jim Jordan Jordan gilt
als Trump Verbündeter und hat sich
skeptisch zu finanziellen Hilfen der USA
für die Ukraine
geäußert im Fall des AFD Vorsitzenden
kopala hat die zuständige
Staatsanwaltschaft bekannt gegeben dass
nach umfangreichen toxikologischen
Untersuchungen keine auffälligen
Substanzen im Blut gefunden wurden im
Arztbrief des Klinikums ist die Rede von
einem Nadelstich im rechten Oberarm Tino
kopaller war während einer
Wahlkampfveranstaltung Ingolstadt in ein
Krankenhaus gebracht worden seine Partei
spricht seitdem von einem tätlichen
Übergriff die Staatsanwaltschaft hat
darauf bislang keine
Hinweise Naturkatastrophen und extrem
Wetter zwingen weltweit Millionen Kinder
zur Flucht laut kinderhilfsswerk unizef
mussten deshalb zwischen 2016 und
2021 mehr als 43 Millionen Minderjährige
ihre Heimat ganz oder zeitweise
verlassen Hauptursache sind
Überschwemmungen Stürme und Dürren laut
der UN-Studie werden diese
Fluchtbewegungen inf Folge der
Klimakrise künftig weiter
zunehmen der Druck auf die Europäer
Lösungen in der Migrationspolitik zu
finden wird jedenfalls nicht geringer
werden zuletzt haben sich die
EU-Mitglieder ja mühevoll auf
Neuregelungen in der Asylpolitik
geeinigt wobei geeinigt relativ ist es
war eine Mehrheitsentscheidung gegen den
erklärten Willen von Ungarn und Polen
und das lassen beide Länder die anderen
spüren auch heute wieder beim EU-Gipfel
in Granada eine gemeinsame Erklärung zur
Migrationspolitik gab es nicht Ungarn
und Polen haben das blockiert rein
formal hat das keine Folgen es ist ein
informelles Gipfeltreffen das eh keine
konkreten Beschlüsse vorsieht was einem
dann auch ewige Nachtsitzungen erspart
aber ein schönes Bild gibt eine solche
Blockade natürlich nicht ab berichtet
Thomas
Walde am Ende beglückwünschte sich der
Gastgeber des Gipfels bei einem
zentralen Thema gebe es
Fortschritt wir haben mit Erfolg dafür
gearbeitet wie her Präsident Michelle
und Präsidentin von der Lin anerkannt
haben dass es eine Einigung gibt bei der
Regulierung von
migrationskrisen eine Regulierung von
Krisen darauf hatte vor allem Italien
gedrungen bei der drohenden Überlastung
eines Landes durch Flüchtlinge sollen
verschärfte Maßnahmen möglich sein wie
die längere Inhaftierung auch die EU
zeigt sich zuversichtlich dass die
krisenregulierung eine politische Krise
beendet das ist sehr wichtig es ist der
entscheidende Baustein für eine Einigung
bei der Migration sass wir nun hoffen
das Paket bald zu
verabschieden doch die Freude ist nicht
so ungetrübt wie heute dargestellt denn
die krisenregulierung sieht eine Pflicht
vor besonders belasteten Staaten
unerwünschte Migranten abzunehmen zwei
Länder verhinderten heute eine
gemeinsame Abschlusserklärung
dazu wir werden rechtlich vergewaltigt
wenn man vergewaltigt wird wenn man
gezwungen wird etwas zu akzeptieren was
man nicht will wie soll man dann noch
einen Kompromiss machen das ist
unmöglich einige haben Angst vor einem
Diktat das aus Brüssel und Berlin kommt
wir haben keine Angst vor diesem Diktat
Deutschland hatte sich zuletzt mit
Italien geeinigt und den Weg zu einer
Lösung freigemacht und glaubt dass eine
Mehrheit sich am Ende gegen Ungarn und
Polen durchsetzen werde doch die Replik
von Bundeskanzler Scholz zeigt wie sehr
der Widerstand nervt das Länder die
gleichzeitig die Migrationspolitik die
auch gemeinsame europäische Versuch mit
irregulärer Migration umzugehen
kritisieren sollten dann nicht
gleichzeitig welche sein die diejenigen
die bei Ihnen ankommen durchwinken damit
sie in Deutschland an kommen und
euvertreter denken bereits weiter die
eu- missission Irini an der die
Bundeswehr beteiligt ist und die ein
Waffenembargo gegen Libyen durchsetzen
soll könnte gegen Schleuserbanden in
Tunesien
Vorgehen ich muss über einbot nachdenken
um vielleicht Irini
einzusetzen aber dafür brauche ich die
Zustimmung Tunesiens denn das muss in
tunesischen Gewässern
stattfinden wir werden immer sorgfältig
wegen müssen ob bestimmte Missionen
erweitert werden können ob das Sinn
macht dabei zeigt sich Tunesien schon
jetzt als schwieriger Partner bei der
Bekämpfung illegaler Migration so sind
solche Überlegungen am Ende auch ein
Eingeständnis dass selbst mühsame
Fortschritte in der EU allein auf den
Meeren wenig
verändern mühsame Fortschritte bei der
EU darüber wollen wir noch ein bisschen
tiefer reden mit unserem
europakorrespondenten Ulf fröller Ulf
Viktor orbn sagt ja heute dass Ungarn
und Polen von der EU vergewaltigt worden
sein zeigt das dass
Mehrheitsentscheidungen in der EU auch
nicht unproblematisch
sind ja das zeigt das und vor allem dass
Orban und auch die Polen große Probleme
haben das Prinzip das wichtige Prinzip
in der EU das demokratische Prinzip der
Mehrheitsentscheidung anzuerkennen und
das ist schon problematisch sie gehen in
eine
Fundamentalopposition was den
Asylkompromiss angeht weil sie sagen
egal was mit Mehrheit entschieden wird
wir werden es nicht umsetzen wir werden
keine Flüchtlinge aufnehmen wir werden
uns weigern das zu akzeptieren und das
ist ein riesenprem weil ein
Asylkompromiss das weiß jeder wird in
Europa nur funktionieren wenn alle
mitmachen und wenn zwei sagen wir machen
nicht mit dann funktioniert er eben
nicht deswegen hat der Bundeskanzler
auch sehr genervt reagiert und hat
gesagt es kann ja wohl nicht sein dass
wenn es ein Kompromiss gibt dass dann
Ungarn einfach nur die Flüchtlinge
durchwingnt nach Deutschland aber wie
man sie zwingen will Polen Ungarn
mitzuspielen diese Regeln zu akzeptieren
das ist bisher nicht erkennbar und
stellt sich Ungarn ja nicht nur bei der
Migrationspolitik quer sondern agiert
auch ziemlich en gegen die
Ukraine ja auch da muss man sagen totale
Fundamentalopposition von Orban er ist
gegen Sanktion er blockiert Sanktion er
ist gegen Waffenlieferung er liefert
auch keine Waffen er ist gegen die ganze
Richtung die die EU eingeschlagen hat
bei der Ukraine und er blockiert immer
wieder sehr gezielt wichtige Finanz
Hilfe finanzielle Hilfe für die Ukraine
und das ist sehr problematisch wenn man
das ein bisschen verallgemeinern will
könnte man eigentlich sagen das was man
in Amerika an tiefer Polarisierung der
Gesellschaft feststellt kann man ein
bisschen nun auch in Europa sehen diese
rechtsnationalen Bewegungen und
Regierung gehen eben zu einer
Fundamentalopposition über und man kann
sich mit ihn nicht mal mehr über
grundsätzliche Fragen wie bei der
Migration und bei der ukraineepitik
einigen und das ist natürlich doch eine
sehr problematische Entwicklung
allerdings danke schön Ulf nach
granadaktor Orb bremst zwar beim
EU-Beitritt der Ukraine gegen eine
andere EU-Erweiterung hätte er hingegen
nichts einzuwenden im Gegenteil eine
Aufnahme der
westbalkanländer befürwortet er die
sechs Staaten warten schon sehr lange
darauf näher an die EU heranzurücken
Albanien beispielsweise brauchte schon
allein 13 Jahre um überhaupt förmliche
Beitrittsverhandlungen aufnehmen zu
können dass das Verfahren jetzt
beschleunigt werden soll das fordert
nicht nur Victor Orban sondern auch die
deutsche Außenministerin die heute zu
einem Treffen in Albaniens Hauptstadt
Tirana gereist ist allerdings
unterscheiden sich die Motive der beiden
Orban hofft auf mehr Einfluss in seinem
Sinne in der EU berbock hingegen hofft
dass damit der Einfluss Russlands auf
dem Balkan ausgebremst werden kann und
als sei das alles nicht schon schwierig
genug droht zwischen Serbien und Kosovo
auch noch ein neuer Krieg Andreas küners
berichtet wir stellen die Leute vor die
Fahnen jetzt sagt Albaniens
Außenminister Hasani und sofort wird die
Entscheidung des Gastgebers in den
Verhandlungsraum gebracht da stehen die
Vertreter von 18 Staaten schon viel zu
lange vor den Kameras und warten auf die
Vertreter von zweien warten auf
Deutschland und Serbien hochgradig
nervvt ist Hasani weil der Streit um
eine Fahne gerade hochgradig eskaliert
als die Tür endlich aufgeht kommt nur
die deutsche Ministerin berbock raus sie
hat es versucht aber Serbiens Minister
daic bleibt sitzen Serbien wird fehlen
auf dem Gruppenbild weil die Leute vor
den Fahnen stehen und weil eine der
Fahnen die goldblaue des Kosovo ist und
so scheitert das westbalkanantreffen
schon an einem Stück Stoff um es klar zu
sagen wir erwarten mehr
Kompromissbereitschaft und wir erwarten
mehr Mut sich dabei auch einmal gegen
innenpolitischen Gegenwind zu stemmen es
geht um viel seit wieder geschossen wird
zwischen Serben und Kosovaren es geht
vielleicht um Krieg oder Frieden an
einem Sonntag im September entdeckt eine
Drohne im Norden des Kosovo diese 30
schwer bewaffneten Männer sie sind
Serben und haben gerade einen Polizisten
erschossen sie sind auf der der Flucht
noch wissen sie nicht dass es in diesem
Kloster zu einem erbitterten
Feuergefecht kommen wird dass auch drei
von ihnen sterben werden fassungslos
ungläubig sieht Europa wen das Kosovo
als Anführer der Paramilitärs
identifiziert einen Bekannten serbischen
Politiker Milan radoutic der auch als
der verlängerte Arm von Serbiens
Präsident wutit gilt ich erwarte eine
klare Haltung der Anwesenden Minister
und alle teilneh hier die die Aggression
Serbiens gegen Kosova stark verurteilt
und auch konkrete Schritte unternommen
werden um Serbien dafür zu sanktionieren
ein Nachbarland angegriffen zu haben
Angriff Aggression völliger Quatsch sagt
Außenminister dit Serbien habe von der
Aktion nichts gewusst aber für ein
versönliches Bild oder gar Wort ist
heute nicht der
Tag Serbien seine tren an der Grenze zu
Kosovo erst verstärkt aber jetzt wieder
reduziert hat ist gut sagt die NATO aber
Kontrolle ist besser mit einer
Aufstockung der kfur Friedenstruppe
intensiviert der Westen seine
militärischen Bemühungen und mit den
Fahnen aller 20 beteiligten Länder seine
diplomatischen und jetzt geht's bei dir
noch mal weiter Heinz mit dem Blick auf
die Wirtschaft es gab heute eine Reihe
neue Daten zur Konjunkturentwicklung in
Deutschland etwa zu den
industrieaufträgen in den USA zum
Arbeitsmarkt wie sieht man an den Börsen
die Lage derzeit Frank betetmann na ja
die wurden ein wenig auf dem falschen
Fuß erwischt denn mit beiden sehr
positiven Entwicklungen hatte man nicht
so recht gerechnet weder in den USA noch
hierzulande dickes Plus bei den
Neuaufträgen in der Industrie im August
verbuchte das verarbeitende Gewerbe 3,9%
mehr Bestellungen als noch einen Monat
zuvor und der Job Boom in den USA hält
an im September fanden 336 000
Amerikaner eine neue Stelle und damit
fast doppelt so viele wie zuvor erwartet
die Börsianer freilich brauchten etwas
länger die ersten Reaktionen waren ohje
wenn der Arbeitsmarkt in den USA so heiß
läuft dann wird die mächtige usnenbank
sicher bald noch weiter die Leitzinsen
anheben und wir alle kennen inzwischen
die Mechanismen dann dauert es nicht
mehr lange bis auch bei uns die Zinsen
steigen und drohen den Wirtschaftsmotor
weit abzuwirken dann aber sah man Mensch
die Löhne steigen gar nicht mehr so
stark der Inflationsdruck ist nicht mehr
so groß und das sorgte für ein Umdenken
der Dow jonesindex am Abend mit über 350
Punkten im Plus zuvor konnte auch der
deutsche leidindex DAX deutlich zulegen
160 Zähler ein versöhnlicher
Wochenausklang also nach einer insgesamt
schwachen Börsenwoche hier in Frankfurt
Frank Bittmann vielen Dank gerne der
neue fußballbundestrainer julian
nagelsmann hat seinen Kader für die
beiden anstehenden Testspiele gegen die
USA und Mexiko Berufen dabei sind gleich
drei debutanten im Aufgebot und auch ein
alter
Bekannter Hummels Dortmunds Abwehrchef
soll die Defensive der dfb1 wieder
stabilisieren Bundestrainer nagelsmann
sieht ihn auch in der Führungsrolle ja
Matz ist ein Spieler mit einer sehr
großen Erfahrung und das auch das was
wir sehen wollen der hat natürlich
exzellenten Spielaufbau er hat immer den
Mut auch Bell ins Mittelfeld zu spielen
von drei neuen Mittelfeldspieler Robert
Andrich von Bayer Leverkusen Premiere
auch für den offensivstarken Stuttgarter
Chris füich überraschend die Nominierung
des kopfballstarken Stürmers Kevin
Berens von Union Berlin wir müssen
versuchen durch eine Art und Weise durch
eine Art undweise wir spielen wollen
doch ein aktiven Fußball eine Stimmung
innerhalb der Mannschaft zu erzeugen die
ja jeden mit GI und Lust auch bei der
Nationalmannschaft spielen lässt auch
dabei Thomas Müller einer von fünf vom
FC Bayern der nicht nur für gute
Stimmung sorgen soll
Berlin leistet sich etwas was wohl keine
andere Metropole hat eine riesige
Freifläche einfach so mitten in der
Stadt das
tempelhoferfeld keine grüne Lunge wie
der Tiergarten oder der Central Park in
New York ein bisschen gegärtnert wird
dort zwar aber zu viele Bäume würden
wohl eher stören beim Drachen steigen
lassen Skaten oder
partypcknicken zeitweise hatten die
Stadtoberen die Idee man könne J doch
Wohnungen bauen die werden schließig
gebraucht aber das wollten die Berliner
nicht und so bleibt das Feld eine große
improvisationsbühne die heute ein
Jubiläum feiert vor 100 Jahren im
Oktober
1923 starteten von hier die ersten
Flugzeuge das historische
flughafenebäude das wurde dann später in
den 30er Jahren errichtet aus Berlin
Stefan
merseburer Berlin feiert 100 Jahre
Flughafen Tempelhof 100 stundenl auftagt
am Abend in der zeitloss schönen
Haupthalle der Flughafen ist ein Erbe
der Nazis und Europas größtes Denkmal
geschütztes Gebäude und wir sind
schließlich in Berlin ein gigantischer
Sanierungsfall 2 Milliarden Euro
mindestens ein Anfang ist gemacht der
ehemalige Tau hat jetzt eine schmucke
Terrasse der Ort ist so groß dass er
ganz viel Leben sorbiert und mehr oder
weniger verschwinden lässt weil es eben
so wahnsinnig große Flächen so große
Räume sind so eine große Ausdehnung ist
und wir versprechen uns ehrlich gesagt
auch von diesem Tower und der
Ausstellung die wir eröffnen schon dass
hier leben reinkommt und dass wir eine
Destination werden Ziel wo man
hinkommt das moderne Treppenhaus wurde
über das alte gelegt zu sehen sind
deshalb auch die Stufen des Nazi robaus
und aus der Zeit der Alliierten eine
kleine Ausstellung zeigt die bewegte
Geschichte
angefangen hat es vor 100 Jahren so ganz
bescheiden nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
sowjetische Blockade und Luftbrücke wiea
Tempelhof sichern Amerikaner und Briten
überleben und Freiheit der Menschen in
den
westsektoven daran erinnert heute das
AlliiertenMuseum es liegt abgelegen im
Stadtteil dalem und will ins Zentrum an
den Ort der Luftbrücke nach Tempelhof
wirollen das ziehen es muss neu
gegründet werden es äh muss die den
Inhalt des Kalten Krieges ähm die
systemkonfrontraation auf eine
prominente zentrale Bühne heben und da
ist dieser Standort natürlich wunderbar
geeignet schon ausgelagert in Tempelhof
sind lauter große Objekte für die in
dalem kein Platz ist das ist Hangar 7
reichlich Platz hierhin soll das
AlliiertenMuseum ziehen irgendwann
zurzeit wird die Betondecke aufwendig
saniert mit Spritzbeton
[Musik]
auch das Technikmuseum und die deutsche
Film und fernsehakademie Berlin sind als
dauerhafte Mieter der Hangar vorgesehen
andere sollen weiter wechselhaft
bespielt werden mit Kulturevents oder
Messen doch momentan werden in zwei der
insgesamt sieben Hallen geflüchtete
untergebracht eine dritte ist im
Gespräch das ist auch mit diesem
Standort mit der Solidarität mit der
Tempelhof auch verbunden wird aus Zeiten
der Luftbrücke ist das für uns nicht nur
politisch gewünscht sondern auch in
unserer DNA als Gebäude hier zu helfen
wenn Not am Mann ist Tempelhof zwischen
aktuellen Nöten und einer Vision für die
Zukunft Kultur Kunst und
Kreativwirtschaft sollen der Legende
Leben einhauchen doch der Weg dahin ist
noch
weit das war's von uns mit der heuthow
geht's gleich weiter und gegen 015r
gibt's dann unser heute schnal Update
mit n te mir wir melden uns morgen
wieder
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter zu den
extremwetterereignissen weltweit in
diesem Jahr gesellen sich auch die
Temperaturrekorde der einzelnen Monate
so war z.B der juni der wärmste juni
seit Aufzeichnungsbeginn aber auch die
anderen Sommermonate waren extrem der
August gesellt sich ebenfalls in diese
Reihe der wärmsten Monate un der Juli
der überragt alle Monate zuvor was sie
hier noch sehen ist ein Herbstmonat der
sich tatsächlich hier einreih und den
kann man durchaus mit den anderen
Sommermonaten vergleichen es war der
wärmste September seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn wir schauen auf die
Nacht und da gibt es regen der
allmählich südwärs driftet ganz im Süden
merkt man davon nichts hier bildet sich
Nebel oder es es Stern klar die
Temperaturen sinken dabei auf 1 Grad im
Süden ziemlich kalt hier ansonsten 16°
ziemlich mild im Nordwesten morgen dann
zieht der Regen weiter und erreicht zum
Abend hin die Mitte vorher ist es hier
trocken ganz im Süden sowieso und hier
scheint die Sonne verbreitet bei
Temperaturen bis 24° im Südwesten hier
schreiben wir also an einem Sommertag
vorbei 15° gibt's ganz im Norden
Sonnenschein und Wärme auch in den
nächsten Tagen am Sonntag im Südosten
Regen WTE bis
26° Montag bis 27° und Dienstag bis
28° damit einen schönen Abend